[Music]
in out news piece submitted by
dinkleberg that's tight dink too bad no
fun Fairly OddParents dinkleberg an
inmate is asking for an electric chair
execution over lethal injection why the
[ __ ] is he like super guilty he's like I
deserve this or he's afraid of needles I
think he's an adrenaline junkie he's
like I want to go out so [ __ ]
craziest I think he has a needle phobia
yeah he's right oh I hate needles what
are the choices can you do the
traditional hanging where they drop your
legs and go punch by gunfire yeah they
do with firing squad
like something that has been I think
hangings there's a lot of mistakes that
happen so they don't die properly lethal
injection is not all that peacefully
really what happens there was this one
dude so it took I I think it was like
about eight hours to die and you're
supposed to die within seven minutes but
he was in so much excruciating pain that
there's this could even say anything
doors is like lips locked like I mean I
don't know well what kind of crime did
he do I don't know that either I just
know that there's this particular drug
what's Guinea to be in a leak in a
Mormon community there's like this one
particular drug that they use for the
lethal injection and that's the one that
is most likely to cause these
complications where it doesn't turn out
the way they expect it to and not only
that but what the [ __ ] did they inject
them with honey mm-hmm I can tell you
that it's my no midazolam midazolam that
sounds fun Jocelyn oh my bedazzled this
[ __ ]
CME's hooker dude midazolam is midazolam
they are also saying that medical
profession professionals they don't even
administer the lethal injection it's
prison employees that do it so they
might like miss the [ __ ] artery or
though they tell the [ __ ] janitor to
come I Webster I need you to get this
[ __ ] well clean right now you'll
tell me to do this right now and then he
ain't pay me for this year thanks office
[ __ ] hey he's all sweaty and as he's
walking his [ __ ] keys give to me give
to me give it to me I think it's okay if
they suffer a little bit that's what
some people is like think about it right
like this like this guy that tortured
and [ __ ] pool what he did is he
killed two people he it was a double
murder they were gonna buy drugs off of
him [ __ ] went bad and he told them oh
and then flip their throats oh it's been
eight hours of pain is fine yeah but
it's the whole I cruel and unusual
punishment things I can handle the
Constitution I don't ever want to commit
any kind of crime well you did when you
wore that shirt today the nipples
I don't think it's cruel and unusual I
think it's fun and spontaneous
I should have been way more funny if you
just didn't laughter how come they're
even entertaining what he has to say
you know like once you're in jail are
your rights are taken away so if they're
like hey we're gonna kill you this way
why are they why is he even going like
hey I want the electric chair instead no
like oh let me think about that hmm
well he has attorneys oh I forgot about
that this is the lesser of two evils
because of the whole like lethal
injection in Fox Oh cuz the 19 that is
[ __ ] thugs last time Tennessee put
some cuz it takes place in Tennessee
last time they put someone to death by
electric chair was 2007 I want them to
develop something like a [ __ ] strong
ass laser that slices through everything
but it goes down and like half a second
like this oh oh what about like a human
body shot like a paper shirt movie made
like hamburger meat out of it I just
don't want to die like that in general I
want to die in my sleep
I mean don't commit any crimes in you're
good if I was there and I had to be
killed and I can choose I'll be like put
me in a rocket and blow me up in space
that's fine do you want them to spend a
billion dollars probably pick a firing
squad for else all right because you
don't even show your face right
or you see it aren't you blindfolded
yeah I think so yeah but you're like and
you don't die right away and you can
still feel what they shoot you in the
lungs right and then now you're drowning
with you know like when you play that
game the rkv electric I don't like that
feeling where do your whole body people
take their freedom for granted man you
guys don't even know how lucky we are
just to be able to walk around and do
what we want [ __ ] yeah I know dude got
out of jail he's been in jail for so
[ __ ] long he was he went to jail
before there was [ __ ] face time of
[ __ ] and stuff like that so it blew his
[ __ ] mind he didn't know what was
going on dude lost [ __ ] 20 years of
his life 20 years man that's like being
in a coma but you're awake yeah it sucks
do you know what I mean
I like my freedom I like going out and
doing whatever the [ __ ] I want I like to
choose not to work every day can you
imagine being like in a cage full of
dudes and you're just fending for your
life non-stop and then finally you get
into the real world and what if you're
like the worst role in that to where
you're like someone's [ __ ] and getting
raped all the time well what if that's
more comfortable because you're gonna
tend to keep your protect yeah yeah
someone loves you if you die -
pretending about cuckoo I can't do that
[ __ ] dude they'll see right through me
you know we're gonna be did you ever
watch the night of huh yeah you're gonna
be that guy that's always sucking the
other dudes
I know su dude that could be really good
at that [ __ ] to come dedicated well then
that's why a lot of guys have trouble
integrating back into society they go
back into jail even though that was
traumatic they're like [ __ ] man they
have to learn how to get along they have
to work nicely with others to learn how
to eat their server without covering up
for it is [ __ ] yeah if they get
disrespected they can't fight or else
they go to jail again imagine there was
a prison where like somehow every
prisoner didn't want to deal with that
[ __ ] and they just like can't we just
have like a nice life in here like we
don't have to work like we're taking
care of like huh how about we just stop
giving each other [ __ ] and then it's
just nice and pleasant and then everyone
wants to go to jail
that's called a retirement home right I
always wanted to know what that felt
like to be in prison - the whole like
dangerous part of it but then that's not
prison right but I just in my own
fantasy world I'm like I wonder what
that would be like you know that's your
fantasy your shitty-ass fantasies the
child
okay as a child you think of like yo man
about the ride is unicorns hit the
[ __ ] sky cut your like being
president you know it's looking another
door for you I've never been in jail but
I know what it feels like to have your
freedom taken away that's what bootcamp
feels like living with your Bob know so
in bootcamp and what's crazy it's like
you don't even know how much freedom you
have day-to-day like the fact that you
could even scratch your face you can't
do that in boot camp you can't scratch
your face no the minute you enter boot
camp you're on someone else's time so
like for example everyone's lined up
right so everyone's standing here you're
not off the scratch your face when you
start in the face yeah yeah the time I
win the time my work its
permission to [ __ ] itch the cheek sir
he's down there I'm standing here for
like however long we need a weight to go
in to eat breakfast you're standing up
for maybe two hours three hours four
hours why everyone marches in grabs food
with the tray or whatever right
because sit down and eat as soon as
you're done eating you stand up you walk
out into a platoon we all go do pull-ups
and we all so you're either in formation
standing together information
single-file line running or working out
or sitting in class like this you can
never scratch your feet you can never a
small talk you can never look around
like there's no free will so that was
like the first time where I was like
when and then at night when we go to
sleep that's when like I was like [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] crazy that's what
everyone gets mind-blowing you hear all
these dudes like crying in the middle of
the night cuz it no one has ever felt
not having freedom in America price so
much that [ __ ] was crazy and then when
you come out when you graduate and
you're like [ __ ] civilian life is
awesome 14 weeks oh god dude that sounds
like 4000 infinity years did it help you
with your discipline oh yeah oh yeah
even like when we do like the swim
training [ __ ] like let's say someone's
drowning right out of the pool go behind
up right there so I hope you just
finished drowning it's still not on
someone else's time now you're just like
always I mean you're not on your own
time you're always on someone else's
time dude I cannot [ __ ] do that man I
got too much [ __ ] sassy attitude for
that [ __ ] did I get kicked out so fast
[Laughter]
but what's craziest once things become
so routine and you know what's how its
predictable you actually find comfort in
it because it now you start knowing the
boundaries of what you are able to do
and not able to do you know any like
once you kind of understand and kind of
feel it up that's your soul is broken
dude that's a probably that's what that
means you've given up on because I was
able to like start observing some
funny-ass [ __ ] from this position
[Laughter]
just gonna be a little bit of yourself
yeah there's some people though who go
into the military like a couple my
friends who went there they I feel like
they're literally their spare got broken
cuz when they came out they came out
different like a different person like a
different person like mentally they got
destroyed we have some of the loot area
friends that are still lazy as [ __ ] yeah
didn't help them I mean my laziness is
so [ __ ] strong I bet you anything I'd
be just like that
I'll just for the boot camp I'll give it
my [ __ ] best and I'll be like that
was a great trip but it would not be a
part of my soul vacation yeah that was
like a Spartan Race yeah I was like that
was a great experience guys now how can
I be lazy just having somebody tell me
what to do makes me [ __ ] itchy like I
just I can't handle that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah right now but doesn't that help you
feel like you're taken care of
huh you know how a lot of guys go back
to jail because they don't have any
responsibilities they get fed they get
taken care of I feel like I would kind
of warm up to that and I see I see why
people become like career military guys
because it's very different from having
it like do everything on your own but
you know my problem is like my biggest
problem like I'd even hear of the word
sandbagging until you said it and then I
looked it up I was like oh [ __ ] I've
been doing that my whole life
what sandbags you just [ __ ] pretend
like you're just not you're always
exhausted and you just can't do anything
dude that's me to the [ __ ] news you
have more in the tank but you're just
like man that's it like you could bench
200 you know and that's what you're
supposed to be rapping but for the work
I'll arms do I 50 pounds [ __ ]
[Music]
you